one
and you are live chairman thank you
good evening and welcome to this central
area planning committee meeting
on wednesday the 31st of march 2021
my name is councillor michael edwards
and i am the chairman of this committee
this meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect
on the 4th of april in response to the
kovit 19 pandemic
there's just a few housekeeping issues
to run through first of all
please could i ask everyone present in
this meeting to ensure your microphone
remains
muted when not addressing the committee
this will reduce background noises and
avoid any
unintentional disturbances this meeting
will be hosted remotely
via conferencing software which allows
members of the public to virtually
attend the meeting whilst being able to
protect themselves and others
and observe the government's lockdown
measures
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent
to being recorded members and officers
during each item please use the hands up
function of the meeting to indicate if
you wish to speak
i would then invite you at the
appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
points of order or indicating that you
must leave the meeting
the chat function should not be used for
questions or any other purpose
when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers please ensure you
reference a page or paragraph number
and keep your contributions as clear and
concise
as possible would invite you to speak
please ensure you turn on your
microphone
now if i may ask officers taking part in
the meeting to introduce themselves
starting with mr lee
good evening members i am matthew lee
the lead specialist place
and chief plan officer of morton
district council thank you
the newly members of michael johnson
lead specialist development management
thank you
good evening members i'm catherine
matthews specialist in development
management
thank you
good evening members my name is katie
fuller i'm clark to this evening's
committee
are there any other officers present
all right before i call on the clerk to
take the royal court of committee
members
can i ask those councillors in
attendance to introduce themselves
please
there are none katie please can you now
carry out or roll caller members to
confirm who is in attendance
thank you of course chairman members
i'll take your name please because you
indicate if you are present thank you
starting with
councillor miss feel
president thank you councillor edwards
are you sorry councillor heard
uh good evening everyone yes i'm
president thank you
councillor lagan
yeah good evening everyone uh president
katie
thank you councillor mays present katie
thank you councillor morris good evening
and welcome
thank you yes here katie good evening
everyone
thank you councillor shawnee good
evening everyone here katie thank you
councillor stiltz
good evening i'm present thank you and
councillor swain
yes good evening present thank you
that's all chairman we have a full house
thank you katie
uh members please be advised that we
have three public participants
in this meeting today and i will call on
them to speak at the appropriate time
please note that they will be in the
meeting with both their camera and
microphone
off until the decision is made on their
agenda item
item two may i have the apologies for
absence please stated
uh we have none chairman thank you
item three minutes 24th of february 2021
it is remain recommended at the minutes
of this meeting held on the 24th of
february 2021
found on pages 7 and 2 8 are approved as
a true and accurate record
i so move and if you wish to second that
motion please hand me your microphone
and state your name there
councillor still
thank you if any member wishes to raise
any matter of accuracy please use the
hands up function to indicate and i'll
invite you to speak
katie please can you advise of any other
member
has indicated a wish to speak no
chairman
uh we have no members indicating they
wish to speak thank you
can i ask members if you wish to agree
the minutes
back to uh uh to agree by ascent
great agreed agreed
agenda item 4 declaration of interest
disclos to disclose the existence and
nature of any disposable pecuniary
interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regards to paragraphs six
to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members members are reminded that they
are also required to disclose any such
interest
as soon as they become aware that this
should the need arise throughout the
meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the hands up function that
doing
to indicate that i invite you to speak
right there's quite a few so who was
first
cancer stilts
thank you mr chairman i will declare a
non-pecuniary
interest in item six on the agenda as i
know one of the neighbors who i believe
is an objector thank you
councillor bird and thank you chairman
i also declare a non-pecuniary interest
that i know the neighbours
uh of uh 21 essex road
thank you councilman
thank you very much chair uh item five
bates road
uh non-pecuniary interest in that i've
received contact
from local residents but of course i've
expressed
no opinion either way thank you thank
you
councillor morris um item five
i am i know the applicant
um non-pecuniary interests um
we don't exchange christmas cards or
never have exchanged bodily fluids so uh
just uh i know the applicant thank you
thank you
councillor logan lagan sorry
that's right council edwards um
non-pecuniary uh
in agenda item number six please and i
have a relative who lives on the road
um no connection but i just feel
um for completeness i will declare a
non-pecuniary interest
thank you chair thank you very much uh
councillor maize
uh thank you mr chairman a non-pecuniary
interest in item number five
as i know the applicant and the uh the
agent
thank you thank you um councillor is
that a legacy
hand
yes i'm sorry chairman i'll take that
off
katie um um can you advise if any other
members have indicated a wish to speak
please i don't believe there are any
other members who
wish to raise a declaration of interest
thank you thank you agenda
item therefore we go to agenda item 5
and on pages 9 to 28 please note that a
member's update in relation to this
application has been circulated
prior to this meeting in a moment i'll
recall on the officer to present this
item
remember as a reminder that if you wish
to speak on this item please make this
known by using the hands up function
within this meeting i will then come to
you in turn
and please keep your points clear and
succinct
mr johnson please can you represent your
report
um chairman um i'll be uh presenting
this um
item sorry yeah okay
please go ahead thank you yes hopefully
i've shared my screen now with the um
powerpoint show yeah
all right so this is
um an application for the construction
of an open-sided storage barn
um on lander jason herbert house
industrial estate and bates road modern
and is a resubmission of a previously
refused scheme last year but it shows
the location
of the site and
it's
sorry just bringing up something else as
well at the same time
so it's north of bates road and the
site's currently vacant
the site is undulating with an existing
um public footpath located on an
embankment which runs along the southern
boundary and the site has a further
public footpath running along the
northeast perimeter connecting bates
road to hall road
and the street to the north the northern
badly site is adjacent to part of the
river black water
and beyond the northeastern boundary the
site is a mixture of residential and
commercial uses
which back onto the site including the
haybridge inn which is a greater listed
building
and the nearest residential property is
10 meters from the site and around 20
meters from the building proposed
the site and joins the keysight
industrial estate
which is um part of a allocated
employment
site as a part of the local development
plan and is also
adjacent to an existing car park the
bridge
um house industrial estate is located in
reddick to the west
the site is in in um flood zone 3b which
is a functional floodplain
and the blackwater estuary ramsar site
and is located around 400 metres of the
southeast
so that's the existing site and the
proposed site plan
so it's proposed to erect um around
1100 square meters of storage and
distribution floor space
in the form of an open-sided barn to be
positioned in the northern end of the
site
so the access from baits road will be um
here in the corner and with the car
parking
in this location and the barn over here
and that 10 meter shows and the distance
between the building on the
the boundary of the site as mentioned
earlier
for these elevations of the building
the building would be um nearly 52
meters in length
and 22 meters in width
floor plan cross section
photos of the site these were um
taken last year but they show the um
hybrid industrial estate on the left
that is looking
north west across the site the top one
and then looking north across the site
the one at the bottom and then you've
got
more views looking southeast across the
site at the top
and looking southwest across the site at
the bottom
so having assessed the having assessed
the proposal
um officers consider that
um development would not comply with the
flood risk sequential test
and is therefore not acceptable from a
flood risk perspective
also have potential harm to the immunity
of the enabling residents
and there is a lack of certainty in
clarity regarding the means of surface
water drainage from the development
and it hasn't been demonstrated that
there's an adequate means of surface
sort of drainage
that will be provided and development
would not result in increase in flood
risk
just to comment on that the um the agent
has
is sent an email in this afternoon with
some further information about
um surface water drainage um but there
hasn't been an
opportunity to assess this and
it is too late in the day to be
submitting
revised details um
for an application that's on already on
the
committee agenda and also take this
opportunity
to remind members that there is a
update on on members update and that's
the consultation response from
environmental health and they confirming
their objection to the proposal based on
its proximity
to residential properties and the nature
of the use and the open-sided
um form of the building that is proposed
thank you chairman thank you
we have two public participants with
this planning application
and in line with the public
participation scheme and i am inviting
to
invite an objector angela mccollux to
read had her submission
may or remind you that you are allocated
two minutes only for public speaking
in accordance with the scheme please
turn your camera and microphone off
when spin is speaking so um mr mccollum
are you there um yes
can you hear me okay i can't see you
right hold on a moment is that on now
this camera on yeah yes yep okay
are you ready for me to start yes okay
right thank you for giving me the
opportunity to express my concerns
i've already submitted a detailed
objection which i assume
you would have already read but my
objection is that the proposed building
is on a flood plain which given the
current climate change and environmental
issues
is inappropriate uh there was an article
in the malden and burned in february
stating that morton district council
were taking steps to ensure a better
environment
so i don't know why with this in mind
planning permission would be
granted i'm also concerned about the
noise and the fumes and the smells
coming from vehicles going to and from
the facility
as this will increase although it's
expected to en
to store empty bins who will monitor
whether the bins are full or empty
the vehicle movements are supposed to be
between eight and nine six arrivals and
nine departures
and between five and six in the evening
two arrivals and six departures
does this mean there will be no further
other movements during the day
and how will anyone know if the vehicles
are going to the proposed site or to
the young current site at the end of the
road
i'm concerned about the impact on the
residents especially those whose
properties back onto the uh
the floodplain there'll also be an
increase in vermin either rats or more
predominantly seagulls who will be
attracted to the site
this will increase the noise and the
fouling as it is already evident in the
current recycling center
and base roads are busy with hgv and
other vehicles including the staff the
road is also already congested with
vehicles parking on the road and grass
verges
and any increase will exacerbate the
problem with the planning application
car companies all always push the
boundaries
i.e increasing working hours vehicle
movements etc
and although i live near the industrial
estate the amount of traffic has
massively increased
over time and i think it's now time to
consider the residents
rather than the businesses i feel that
greens have outgrown their facility and
is now in the wrong place
this type of business that they operate
thank you thank you miss uh mr
mcconnell i now invite mr paul calder
the agent to read out their submission
may i remind you that you allocate
you are allocated two minutes only for
public speaking in accordance with the
scheme
and please turn your camera and
microphone off and finish speaking
so mr uh caller thank you good evening
members
um i'll keep this speech brief and focus
on the case officer's reasons for
refusal
the first is that the proposal fails the
sequential test
a detailed sequential test was submitted
as part of the application
which looked at a number of sites
available on the open market located in
flood zones one
two and even three the assessment found
that no
suitable alternative sites for the
proposed development existed within the
area
i'd also like to point out that the site
did have
does have a lawful planning consent for
car parking like the two sites adjacent
to it
and the principle of open storage along
it with the form of a dutch barn
was found acceptable through the grant
of planning permissions in 2010 by the
authority a flood risk assessment has
been submitted as part of the
application
and during the determination of the
previous application the case officer
refers to as being refused earlier last
year
raised no comments to the proposal um
i would like to highlight that the
second reasonable fuse will relate to
lead local flood authorities held an
objection
we have provided additional information
uh to address this concern
and if we'd been allowed more time to
reconsult with the lead local flower
authority
i'm sure that we'd they would have
removed their holding objection they
have not objected on the principle
merely that some additional information
was required turning to the third point
and the
about regarding noise disturbance the
noise monitoring assessment was
submitted as part of this application
and this showed no harm would be caused
from noise emissions given the site's
location directly adjacent to the
existing residential industrial area
further
when deciding the application earlier
this year the council's own
own environmental officer raised no
objection
or comparable technical data to address
the noise monitoring that we've
undertaken
it is noted that they have not commented
on this application
i do note that the case officer said
that coming but that's coming on monday
and again we haven't had suspicion of
time to address their comments
um so i'll just leave that point there i
believe this would boost employment
within the local area i should stress
this has no relation to green recycling
this is an open sided storage barn
located adjacent to an existing
industrial area
which would employ some employment
within the local economy which is very
italian's current time
thank you thank you very much mr carter
okay um members
i will now open the debate and invite
you to make any comments from the report
but i would like to go first of all if i
made to
the wall council of cancer made because
this was a calling
so cancer made would you like to start
after debate
uh yes thank you very much mr chairman
um
i'm finding this uh application somewhat
confusing
uh reading the documentation
um perhaps an officer can explain to me
um
exactly what a holding objection is and
why
that would even be a thing on such a
site
also um there seems to be some confusion
as to what this is actually going to be
used for
my understanding is it has no connection
as was just said by the
um the agent to the
um recycling center although the owner
is the same person again that that also
confuses matters
there also is confusion over the
sequential testing
that has been um undertaken um
and i've been trying to attempt to find
out exactly
the extent of flood flood zone 3b
because if this is um
the the case that this particular
application does sit on a flood at zone
3b
how much more of this particular
industrial area
sits within that flood zone behind
existing flood defenses
um i'm very concerned that
this matter has not actually been
addressed or doesn't seem to be being
addressed
and there is so much confusion in what
i've been reading
both on this application and on the
refused application
no mention was there of flood zone 3b
on the first application that was was
refused
yet this is now being put on this
application
as um something that is in existence all
of a sudden
why wasn't it um mentioned on the first
application
um perhaps you can help me out
thank you councilman uh can i ask any
officers
if they can respond to uh cancer major
queries
yes thank you uh thank you chairman the
um
the first question was about what is a
holding objection
so the essex county council said team
have um basically said that
there isn't enough information or does
the the wrong information
um that has been submitted so they they
don't
so they are objecting on the basis of
the information that's available
but by a holding objection suggests that
um
then the applicant may be able to
overcome their concerns by providing
more information um or tweaking
or changing slightly what the
information that they submitted
and so basically it is an objection but
one potentially could
could be overcome with further
information so in this case
holding objection was was um given
and the applicant has agent has provided
further information
which said have had an opportunity to
review but that hasn't addressed their
concerns so they're maintaining their
holding objection
and hopefully that explains what um
what they mean by holding objection um
in terms of what's going to be used for
the as part of the application
there is reference to different types of
uses
um in no different documents say
slightly different things but the um
but the proposal overall is for a
storage and distribution news it's not
for any specific use or user
um within that youth class so the if it
was
was approved um it would be for um
a general b8 storage and distribution
user not for
um any particular user or any particular
type of use
and provided it felt within that used
class
um in terms of sequential testing
and the extent of protozoan 3b
which is a functional flood zone um
so the um the
in terms in order to do a sequential
test that has to be
demonstrated there's no other um
land available or reasonably available
for the type of use proposed
um on in a an area that has lower flood
risk
um so in this case the applicant did do
a sequential test um but they only
considered
a land that was in in the immediate
vicinity of malden and haybridge
and they well they made a vicinity of
the site
um and they didn't look at sites um
further afield
um or even outside um the malden and
haybridge
can you hear me now
yeah so so the office's um issue is that
the the sequential test didn't cover a
wide enough area
and if they had had um
looked at a wider area they would they
would have found sites that
were in lower flood risk area which this
development could go
ahead on and for example there are sites
um
located in the local plan for
employment uses off wick hill which are
in flood zone one
um and they're also other sites
identified elsewhere in
in in the district so that was the issue
with the sequential test
and in terms of the um fled zone 3b
that's a functional flood zone
and the environment agency didn't
provide a consultation response as part
of the previous application
and but they did as part of the current
application and as far
as part of their response to the current
application they have advised
that the site is within the functional
floodplain
or confirmed that it is within the
functional floodplain and that explains
why
um officers are now talking about it
being flood zone 3b
rather than just phillipstone three um
so but the last application and this
application
the site has always been identified as
being a high risk of flooding whether it
was
functional floodplain or not and the
same process would need to be
gone through in terms of sequential
tests whether it was
um 3a or 3b and then the functional
floodplain
so it has changed slightly um
but the conclusions um are still are
still the same
um much of the adjacent
industrial state is also within the
functional floodplain
um but as part of the allocation of that
site
um it was part of the local plan this
sequential chase would have been gone
through
as part of identifying sites within the
um within the local plan and
identifying them and basically the
allocation
the adjacent education was for the
existing industrial area
um and didn't include lands such as the
application site which was a
essentially a green field and a new site
um and therefore that's why they're
they're next to each other but they
would be um
approached differently if there was that
um proposals for
redevelopment um of part of the addation
industrial state that would
be looked at or assessed differently in
terms of flood risk um
than the current application site which
is um
um outside the allocation and hasn't
been subject to a sequential test
um as part of the application allocation
process
that has needs to be part of a
sequential test as part of the
application process
and hopefully that gives members enough
um
information without going into too many
too many details um
i think i've answered i'll try to answer
the query reason or um yeah the queries
that cancel amazes
raise but if not please let me know and
uh i'll try again thank you
come back on that yes yeah just just
very briefly
thank you very much it isn't um easy i i
understand that
um the the requirements for um
flood zones uh 3b are very much higher
the limitations um on what this land
could or couldn't be used for
um are very much reduced uh with
with flood zone 3 3b um basically
you're looking at you know anything to
do with the water um and water
activities
the the site has had extant planning
permission as a car park
um and i don't quite understand why
an open-sided barn would cause um
so much harm to the site that that could
already be
a place to store cars um
i'm i'm a bit i'm a bit perplexed by
that
and i'm also concerned that in in the
first instance we didn't
we didn't get a response from the
environment agency
bearing in mind it the whole of the
industrial site
on the causeway is an in is in flood
zone three
whether that's a or b and we still
haven't been able to bottom out exactly
the extent of flood zone
3 a and or b across the whole of this
site and what the implications are going
forward
for any development that may be done
within
the ldp areas or adjacent to any ldp
areas
um thank you very much for uh your time
though thank you
thank you councilman uh councillor
morris library was next
thank you councillor edwards i noticed
that um mr lee
has got his hands up i was just
wondering if uh you'd allow me to give
way to mr lee
um and then have my turn please chair
okay thank you
uh mr lee
i can't see you yeah chairman yeah i'm
there
um yeah i did i've got it up it's fine
um sorry bella just for a little bit of
clarity members i think for context
um they may be interested to understand
that
planning flooding wasn't
a particularly large consideration in
the termination of planning applications
prior to the publishing of pps25 in 2006
so
there are going to be lots of houses
employment land
everything and anything you know across
the country in areas that
now we wouldn't be encouraging
development due to flooding but anything
that was pre
2006 it wouldn't really have been a big
consideration for us as decision makers
when
coming to a recommendation so just
thought for a bit of context if you want
what if you're wondering why are there
industrial sites that are historical in
flood zones that would have been why and
you know that's the same reason we have
housing areas in it
and all things like that so i'll just
like give a little bit of context for
you historical hope that's helpful
thanks thank you mr lee council morris
thank you chairman um i'd just like to
say that if i got a little bit of peace
i apologize
um i i have looked at this quite
thoroughly now
and i'm actually quite surprised that
we're using the flood
thing to uh knock this back one of the
reasons
because we've got 1300 houses going into
haybridge
and and we've we've agreed um to build
on floodplains we've we've got holloway
road was recently put in
and that floods regularly so it just
sort of like smacks a little bit that uh
we won't let a business expand
um to basically you know put an
open-sided barn on their car park
um what i would remind members is that
haybridge is growing massively we've
we've got
hundreds of houses going in you know if
you include
the houses that are going to be on the
bypass we will have thousands of houses
going in
these houses are going to need services
and refuse
is one of them so it would seem
that we would be very very silly
to ignore expanding this business when
you consider that if we lose this
business
or if this business goes out of the
district we're just going to have more
congestion on the roads which is
probably going to be worse for the
environment the infrastructure
needs to be improved to take into
account the extra houses that have been
forced on us
and this is hopefully going to be
helpful
um it's it's a hard sell to get
a a refuse company anywhere
because of the stigma surrounding the
business no one wants
a skip company a refuse company to be
anywhere near
their property but it would be easier to
expand this business
and help the local community not just
with the employment but with the
infrastructure
rather than just um turn it down i would
like to know as well
could um any of the officers please tell
me when was the last time bait road
flooded
please
um through chairman sorry i wouldn't
know
um that from an officer point of view
mr lee if you've got any idea when was
the last time bait's road flooded i know
it might be at risk of flooding but when
was the last time it flooded
thank you chairman um off the cuff now i
wouldn't have the answer but i don't
think it's actually material
consideration determination of the
application because obviously
this is about flood risk but also this
is the functional flood plains this is
the place where
if and when there ever was a flood the
water goes to to
not go to other places so that's why
it's actually so important we protect
these pieces of land because if we don't
we're actually going to cause
exceptional or exacerbate the harm to
other existing businesses
premises and properties if there is
flooding and i do think it's worth
highlighting that
the environment agency have actually
stated if we um in their response if
you're reminded to approve the
application contrary to this advice we
request that you
contact us to allow further discussions
and or representations from us
in line with the town country pac you
know and
under those powers actually have the
right to actually basically get the
secretary of state to request to call it
in so
this is not something they quite they
often you know we get a lot of
application flood zone it's not normal
for them to actually put that paragraph
on so i think
members should be aware of that that is
the level of importance that
the environment agency are flagging on
this application as a concern if members
were to go against the recommendation
thank you chairman
thank you thank you cancer chair through
the chair so
basically the place is never flooded
it's a flood risk but it's never flooded
um when you've got places like holloway
road that flood regularly
that we've with okay building on
uh makes pretty much no sense to me
what what i do believe we need to do is
is explore
exactly where this information is coming
from and
and get to the bottom of that one
because if the place has never flooded
or how can it be a flood risk we've got
places that regularly flood that we've
okayed
it just seems very nonsensical thank you
chair
thank you council morris um who's next
cancer swain
yeah uh thank you chairman
um yes i don't i don't uh quit with
councillor morris on the
importance of trying to do something
about a better arrangement for
alleviating um flooding and um
holloway road and other parts there but
i don't think that is
um that's quite a separate issue really
from
uh this particular um area
i think there's a lot of ambivalence
about um about this area
um it's not identified as a industrial
area in the ldp
it's just been roped in generally into
the um
central area master plan regeneration
area and yet it isn't really a
regeneration
site um it's arguable whether it is an
extension to the existing industry their
state or not
um and um to
to go to the um
other ambivalences or ambiguities
we seem to have limited environmental
objections in some ways and yet the
in 523 the area was cited as of local um
ecological importance um
on the question of um flooding
um the county council of suds
team obviously want a lot more um
to be done by way of suds but i think
that ceiling really emphasizes that
you can't simply allow the water from
this area to um
to run off um or it won't run off um
because of the
um the low lying they drop it on
on floodplain 3b or flood risk area 3b
right next to the creek i don't
accept the argument that the area is a
mixed
residential industrial area i think it's
they're quite separate really
uh if only because you've got the creek
running between
there and the housing and also this is
treated as being a green corridor
so it's quite clearly demarcating
one side from the other i can
see the the
failure on the sequential test to be
almost inevitable and it's difficult
actually
to this is what kind of um activity
would actually um development there
rather than somewhere else in the
district um
uh so
it just looks like we don't really know
i mean the amount of
employment involved is fairly minimal
we don't really know what the best use
of this land really is supposed to be
but it doesn't look like
it's as an industrial area or industrial
site because of all these problems
so i accept all these grounds that the
officers have put forward for refusal
i think it would be harm to neighbours
from this open-sided um
uh bomb and and um
activity there and i think it obviously
fails on this sequential test um
the studs um demo
bonded are so much more than the present
that um that simply underlines the the
flood risk and
i think it gives me of dealing with
flood risk in areas like that um have
having increased and there is also the
unspoken question about
contaminated um runoff from
areas from vehicle uh
or um fumes
tyre um deposits and so on um and where
these would go this doesn't seem to be
tracked
at all um but presumably would just
simply run off into the creek as a
contaminant
um so all in all i would endorse the
officer's refusal for this application
thank you council swain uh councillor
heard
um thank you chairman uh just a couple
of questions on page
13 uh it talks about a lack of
certainty and clarence a clarity
regarding the means
of surface water drainage
it does say on page 22
that the suds team object to this
but is it because they've put forward
two plans and they haven't decided which
one it is
um and my other question is on page
27 and this relates
to um the
sorry i've got to go to page 27 now um
the development uh would has the
potential to calm
to cause harm to the occupiers and then
it says
particularly due to noise disturbance
are there any other um
potential causes of harm other than
noise
please thank you chairman thank you
councillor can any of the officers
assist with that please
um yes thanks thank you through your
chairman um
the one of the objections from essex
county council said is that there were
two schemes
proposed and their advice was that they
should just be
the one and but they also had criticisms
of
both schemes whichever one
the applicant chose to go chose to
pursue um so that hasn't been resolved
um
satisfactorily and certainly to the
satisfaction of
essex county council said and so far
in terms of other issues other than
noise and
and neighbors um i mean other issues
have been
the potential pieces have been raised in
terms of um
smells or odours depending on what is
actually stored at the site
but um the predominant concern would be
the noise
of uh loading and unloading
and other associated activities
with them with a storage distribution
use
um by its very nature thank you thank
you thank you sharon
who has cancer stills
uh thank you i think councillor lagan
was before me but i would have liked to
have heard from the other world member
which is councillor nan
um especially on the bit to do with
archaeology
um on page 24 at 5.8.1
because i think that would be quite
interesting as well
can i go to cancer dragon first i didn't
see you there sorry cancer legend
thank you thank you councillor still so
it's very kind of you um
just a couple of points i just think we
this motion should have been moved first
before the debate
um so just just to say that um
there's lots of uh interesting
conversation here there's a few things
that have come up
in the the debate first i've got a
couple of questions
the first one um to note is how many
letters of objection have been received
with regard to this development
um concerns i have are with again with
the sequential test
that the officer has given us um some
quite deep good detail to consider it as
part of the debate
the risk of flooding is high we will
flood in this area
we haven't had it since 53 but it will
flood the
the um advice and information that mr
lee gave us
with regard to you know historical
decisions and planning
that that's um upsetting and and
sometimes distasteful for us
but um we can't consider that as part of
this application
uh i are concerned that in the offices
report
um in the addendum at 7.3 one of the
areas where they talk about was
was that the ea may not allow acoustic
barriers so there is noise going to be
produced from that
and in our our main report in section
5.313
it talks about the the development that
would have a materially
adverse impact on the setting of listed
buildings
so from a heritage and a an
environmental aspect
it will cause harm but more concerning
to me is 5.4 the impact on the residents
because it talks in 5.4.3 quite clearly
that our own policies and d1 has
improved in the ldp
to ensure that the just protect the
immunity of its surrounding areas taken
into consider
consideration privacy overlooking uh
outlook noise smell
daylight visual impact pollution and so
on so
so forth um so this this
would contravene if we supported this
our own policies
so um their concerns i have especially
for the people that are around there
the bulk and the size of the the
proposed
development and i'm minded to to
support the officer's recommendation for
refusal
thank you chair thank you thank you for
giving away
uh council lagoon can i uh sorry mr lee
can i just ask you to clarify the reason
why
we no longer need to require a motion
before debate
for you chairman um there yeah
my back's like yeah um so i wasn't
expecting to have to give a comment on
the
the process um
part of the restructuring the whole way
that we started to deal with committees
obviously did slightly change and the
planning committees have been basically
treated the same as a lot of the other
committees in this new process but
there is a slight difference between a
planning committee and one of the normal
committees because
actually members at the moment are
discussing the proposal not the
officer's recommendation
which is different to a normal committee
where you are discussing the
recommendation
of a report so i noticed only it might
seem like a bit of a
you know it's it's nothing really
different but it's just a sort of a
point of clarity so members at the
moment are not actually
discussing whether or not it should be
approved or refused person say they're
just
discussing the merits of the proposal so
there was a slight difference that's why
there's no longer a need to
move the officer's recommendation first
for
a planning committee i hope that's
explained some of it
thank you chicken just come back for
that mr lee
thank you i'm always always here every
day's a school day thank you
uh councillor bill sorry if you've been
sitting there quite a long time
your hand up yeah thank you chairman um
this this for me is all about flooding
as well
i mean um call me old-fashioned but it
used to be a riverbed
we well it used to be a creek and the
environment agents thought it was
cheaper to actually block that off
rather than actually maintain that
length of water
so it was it was actually flooded by the
river black water
it is an area of ecological importance
and the last time we had loads of rain i
went down and took pictures of this site
and the well i don't know what you want
to call it
stream at the normally but it actually
turned into a torrent and it was about
eight inches
from the level of the site that is
actually currently
under the plan in there but i mean it
got pretty close
to flooding the whole of that area um
the reason um councillor morris asked
his bates road ever flirted
we know it wouldn't because that was all
part of the river and obviously we've
had a lot of changes with climate change
but that's the reason for the embankment
behind
the industrial estate that's why it will
never flood
because it is basically it's a flood
attenuation that's what it was basically
there for
and it is well supposed to be maintained
because i've actually had environment
environment agency down there clearing
the creek because it was so congested
with
beer barrels and everything else we've
had 10 objections that was another
question someone else asked
um and the 10 meters from site literally
is the other
from the path it's literally just across
the stream that it is at the minute
but it's not practical for any sort of
business
it really ought to be i don't know
a park of some sort i mean they've
already ruined the um
the aspect with the animals that were
there because they've basically cleared
the site already
they've already put an entrance road in
so they've basically started already
and i mean the property you're going to
have them vehicles right up
near enough right opposite where all of
the um
private accommodation is um
and i mean it's not going to exacerbate
the congestion around bait road because
basically uh it's an industrial estate
anyway
but that's the main thing i would say it
was very very close to over top in
last time we had serious rain which is
why i took pictures of it
literally seven to eight inches off of a
literally flooding the whole site
and that is really what the reason it
was done by the environment agency to
basically capture water
because i don't know whether you all
knew but all of the
road water that comes off of hull road
that all goes in to that creek in
between the pub and the
first private house so that that also
exacerbates it
not to mention the fact that it's not
really kept clear
um but that's down to the environment
agency so yeah i mean it's it's a real
issue with flooding
it really is okay thank you cancer bill
council nun did you want
you were invited to comment did you want
to comment
um i was asked about the archaeology uh
mr chairman
i didn't raise my hands to uh discuss
the recommendation because of the point
that councillor lagan made that it
hadn't been moved for debate
uh but um mr lee has clarified the
position there so
we're not actually talking about the
officer's recommendation at the moment
are we we're just
talking about the application uh in
terms of um
the archaeology um that uh cancer stilts
has asked about
that the ditch that we know of today
uh some people have referred to as as
haybird's creek
um was originally the main channel of
the river blackwater
and you know what we think of uh
nowadays as the blackwater
runs from uh bradwell all the way to
malden up to uh just short of full
bridge
and into the area that we now know as
hey bridge creek
that was the main channel of the river
and
it it had a strand which is a beach
uh roughly where hebrews church now
stands
the causeway regularly flooded on the
tide in the 18th and 19th centuries as
well
so in terms of archaeology there is
a lot to take into account in terms of
the riverbed
uh and uh it's a bit controversial this
but it has been suggested that
uh that area was the original landing
point
uh uh uh connected with the battle of
malden but uh
we we won't go there there tonight so
archaeologically i think it's
important and that has been highlighted
uh on uh
5.8.1 of the
report as a material consideration thank
you very much
thank you um council morris is that a
legacy handler on your
new one
um cancer still your legacy hand
no actually i was going to ask a couple
of questions
after that um one is on 5.7.7 and it's
something from
councillor bill has mentioned um in
5.7.7 it says
um appraisal and by easy archaeology
would be required by a condition
well if they've already removed
um vegetation and that which would have
helped the animals on the site how could
we then put
or look at the uh ecology of that
site so that's a bit worrying is that we
don't
now know what was on that site before
they started work on it
and the other one was to do with 5.8.1
which was basically saying that there
will be
considered matter about the archaeology
and how they're going to
um address that so is that going to be a
desktop
archaeological survey or is this
actually going to be an archaeological
dig
i know which one i would prefer but i
would like to know what the officers
would put down as a condition
um yeah through you through chairman the
um
the condition now if planned permission
was granted the condition would be as
recommended by
essex county council archaeology um
which i would have to look up to see
exactly what the wording they used
um it would be one of their standard
ones
um it was certainly more than a watching
brief so
it would be um it would be an assessment
to
establish the um the
potential significance of the
archaeology on the site and that would
be partly desktop
and looking at the um all the records
that
exist already in in in consultation with
this is county council archaeology who
are obviously
the experts on this matter and then if
if the
the potential was um um
what if it looked likely that there was
archaeological interest on the site
then yes there would potentially be you
need to be some
trial trenches doug to um establish
um whether there was anything of uh
archaeological interest under under the
ground um
but i think even if um
and then there's also requirements that
you know if that they have an
archaeologist
on site while they're digging just in
case there's anything
um um is uncovered as part of that
process so it would all be
um managed and um and agreed with
essie's county council archaeology in
advance of any um
development works carried being carried
out in terms of the economy of the site
then yes um it is acknowledged that um
the site of ecological niche the site
has certainly been reduced through the
through the removal of the vegetation um
earlier part of last year
um but but the ac county council
archaeology has recommended that uh
permission is granted their condition is
is attached to
um to to deal with the um
the issue of um ecology again i'd have
to check to see exactly what they um
what they said in their consultation but
it was um but there would be
opportunities to
um improve the
um biodiversity of the site
and there are areas of the site that
will be won't be um
built on or hard surface so there is an
opportunity there
to make some positive
benefits and from an ecological point of
view
thank you thank you uh mr matthews um i
think we've done a good debate on this
did i see your hand
oh sorry councillor mays
uh yeah thank you very much mr chairman
if i could come back just very quickly
um i'd like to thank officers for for
the for the work they've done on this it
it hasn't been easy
um and i've fought very hard for
information on it
um one of the things that i i just
wanted to to clarify
this site has extant planning permission
for a
a car park does that mean
notwithstanding what we've just been
talking about particularly in relation
to the archaeology
um that they could if they wanted to
cover it in concrete
that's the question to make it a car
park
which it already has permission for um
i don't know the answer to that question
i i i
think that does really concern me
particularly in relation to
to the to the the um the information
that we've heard about the archaeology
as well as the ecology of the site and
the importance as far as it being
a flood zone thank you
yeah through chairman there is um as has
been referenced there is a
historic planned permission back in 1996
um which was partially implemented so um
so there is that extent planned
permission and part of which this
site was going to be used at the car
park um
i would need to check the planning
permission um
to check to see what the details of the
car park element was but
um certainly the um the car park would
would involve
hard surfacing the site um again there
may there may have been conditions
um attached to that plan permission um
linked to
archaeology and um um other things that
they would need to do before they um
constructed the car park
but um but because that that that
permission
is um so so long
ago then i suppose the the question
people know if they've had permission
that long or with the likelihood of it
actually being being done now so i think
there is an argument there to
um place limited weight on the fact that
um there is a plan permission
um for car parking but but it is there
and in theory yes it's something that
that could be done thank you thank you
um okay can i just quick really
point sorry just to echo um
what um mrs matthews just said um
and just give members a little bit of
case law in relation to fallback
position which is what an extent
permission is is a full-back position
and that is a material consideration for
the determination of any application
um but what also has to be is the
likelihood of that permission ever being
implemented so
it's sort of conversation we normally
have a lot more about committed
development extensions on houses and
things but
it goes exactly the same for something
like this and as matthew said
that permission is over 20 years old now
and and that
the owner or no no developers take an
opportunity to take that forward so i
think
in all likelihood the um the chances of
that
permission coming forward anytime soon
is limited and therefore
should really be given a a weight that
accords with the reality of what has
happened over the last 20 odd years
thank you chairman thank you mr lee
um okay um i think we've debated this
quite fully
and uh i will go then for the
recommendation
and the recommendation is to refuse for
the reasons as detailed in section eight
of this report
um i've got to have a second please
counseling
a second thank you
um do you want a a recorded vote or uh
buy a sect record if i please chair okay
matthew can you do that please
i'm sorry
fine chairman um so members we are
voting
for the officer's recommendation to
refuse the planning application for the
reasons as detailed in section 8 of the
report
members i'll take your name please could
you indicate if you are for
against or abstaining starting with
councillor miss bill please
thank you councillor edwards
four head
four second
four please 18. mays
thank you councillor stilts paul
thank you and councillor swain
thank you that is nine four and one
against
no abstentions thank you therefore this
application has been refused
as um agreed
can i move one knight to item six please
um
pages 29 to 37
please note that a member's update in
relation to this application has been
circulated
prior to the meeting in a moment i will
call on the officer to present this item
reminder that if you wish to speak on
this item please make this known by
using the hands up function within this
meeting
i will then come to you in turn and
please keep your points clear
and succinct um
it's again um miss
matthews yes yeah
thank you chairman do your report please
send it
okay so this is right
this is an application for um a single
story front rear and side extensions
at 21 essex road malden
and that's a location plan location plan
showing so it's a semi-detached house
just always image attached house
and then we've got existing and proposed
block plan existing on the left
and proposed on the right showing the um
singles through extension and wrapping
around the rear and part the side of the
property
with um an enlarged porch on the on the
front so we've got existing plans and
elevations
so the existing um attached garage
and the rear conservatory would be
removed
and then um a single story say
side and rear extension would be would
be added with the porch on the front so
you've got the elevations there
on the front part the um
the side extension would be flat roof
but the
elements on the front and to the rear
would be
having two roofs
and so this application follows the
refusal of a planning permission
um which included a first floor element
to the side
of the property and these are the
elevations um
showing those just for
information some photographs of the
existing property
showing the attached garage and the
properties on
the property on the um the nearest
property
number 23 essex road they've got front
elevation
front view and a rear view on the bottom
sorry that's all and so the um the
application has been recommended for
approval the previous refusal was solely
based on the
first floor element of the um that was
part of the previous application this
has now been removed
and therefore obviously considered the
previous concerns have been addressed
and therefore the application is
recommended for approval thank you
thank you um we have one
public participant for this planning
application and in line with the public
participation schema now invite the
applicant
this is lorraine press to read out her
submission
may i remind you that you are allocated
two minutes only for public speaking
in accordance with the scheme and please
turn your camera and microphone off when
finished speaking
so much suppress me there
i'm here can you hear and see me yes
i have a question first am i meant to be
reading out what i
sent over to you yesterday
uh no mrs press you can read you can
speak how you wish
that's good because i didn't keep a copy
um
so as previously advised sorry good
evening everyone as previously advised
this was a resubmitted application
from a two-story side extension
and i totally understand and accept the
reason for the refusal because
in keeping with the appearance of the
area by having that side extension
it would have made it look like a four
house terrace
so um the only concern meant
last time was the fact that it would
have
a poor impact on the local area i've now
removed the side extension but
maintained the rear extension and the
front porch
and bringing out the front garage very
slightly
um the um everything
other than the side extension was
considered to
fall in line with the appropriate um
requirements um i think the only
objection was from
number 19 being a loss of light
to their property their property is
a conservatory with a glass roof
and therefore i don't understand how
there would be a loss of light and
there's no consideration um for a loss
of privacy loss of light
or representing an unable uh view
and therefore i'm not really sure why
it wouldn't be approved on this occasion
because i've complied with everything
that was requested
i do note that there is a requirement
for the maple
to have a a three metre barrier around
it and that's noted and agreed
during construction and that's all i
have to say thank you
thank you very much mrs chris um
members i will now open the debate
invite you to make any comments on the
report
now i believe if i can go to the ward
councillor uh as it was according
to councillor seancy would you like to
start off the debate
you're muted
sorry chairman yes thank you um
the um concern is in indeed
um not with the porch or the side
extension
but um the the back
section of the extension um because
because of loss of light for
um i believe it's number 19 the neighbor
and i believe they have they do have um
high windows on that sir
can i just interrupt you sorry mrs press
can you please turn off your camera
thank you okay
sorry thank you chairman
um yes i believe it is more um
as mrs press said that there is
a see-through roof whether it's glass or
whatever
on number 19's conservatory but they
have got
windows on that side as well albeit
high windows um but if this
um new the back part of the extension
goes
up to the boundary which um i believe
by the um plans that um
um ms matthews has shown us
um then that there will be lots of light
for these
higher windows on number 19's concert
conservatory so that is the concern
chairman thank you
thank you um councillor hood
thank you chairman um i'm looking at
page 34
um and it's at 5.3.4
and this is in relation to the
extension uh would sit on the shared
boundary with number 19
essex road and uh from
i think from what is saying um that
there will be also
some alignment with the garage at the
front which may affect
23 as well am i correct with that
um through chairman it might be useful
um maybe for me to share my screen again
show the um
the proposed block plan um
so this is number 19 here um with the
conservator at the rear and it shows how
far out the single story extension
comes and also bear in mind it's a lean
too so
um this um the eaves height here would
be
um lower than the side here
and then in terms of the garage and that
that's shown to be
in line with the um the neighboring
property and doesn't come out further
than
than the neighbouring property um
right hopefully that answers your
question yes okay thank you
so uh i i can't see um
any uh planning issues uh
in relation in relation to this um
but what i would ask that if my members
are minded to approve this application
that one of the conditions of this
proposal
would be that any work should not
uh impinge upon the neighboring
properties
and obviously any damage would have to
be made good so that's the condition i
would request
chairman thank you council heard
mr lee your hand is up yeah
for you chairman i thought i should just
comment on the point just raised by
council heard um that would fall under
the party wall act and would be civil
uh legislation wouldn't be something we
could impose a condition on
um it's separate matter to a planning
matter it's not
there's lowering place that you're not
allowed to
uh damage your neighbor's property one
extending yours so um
that it's it's not saying we would be
able to enforce it wouldn't be it won't
meet the six tests of the conditions
that'd be my suggestion to members
thank you thank you
do you want to come back cancer sure
decision if i met if i may chairman yes
thank you very much
um i would i would like to ask either um
miss matthews or mr lee um if they know
of these um as i say upper windows on
the conservatory of number 19
we were shown a photograph of it at town
council planning
and it was of great concern to the
um councillors at that meeting so
i would like um some clarification on
that please
i do believe them to be there
thank you
um i can um i'd have to check the file
to see whether any other photos
um any others than that that was shown
and just now in the presentation because
that photo doesn't
include the um conservatory at number 19
but um
if you give me um a few minutes i can um
have a look and see see what's on file
i'll go to
uh councillor stilts while you're doing
that perhaps yes thank you mr chairman
i'm just wondering why
uh we sort of mention number 19
at 5.3.2
but at 5.3.6 when we're looking at
um any impact on the neighbours we only
talk about number 23 number 19 is not
mentioned
anywhere um so do they feel that number
19 won't have any
impact uh because they're actually not
mentioning it
do you chairman isn't that mentioned in
five point three point four of the
officer's report
yeah yeah they're they've both got
separate paragraphs to deal with each
property separately
thank you mr lay yeah
um okay so uh
these matches are you any luck
um i am still looking i
probably not far far off
give me um a couple more minutes
i think i
you see that
yes is that visible yet
yes yes so that's um that's a view
standing in the on the application site
first four level looking down into the
garden and that's the
conservatory that i think has been
referred to um with the high-level
windows above the um the brick wall
yes through you chairman yes that's
quite right ms matthews
okay thank you
um windows along the side
of the conservatory there
above fence height
yes i think i'm still sharing my screen
so you've got the
the fence um line and beyond
the neighbours extension you've got a
brick wall here
um part wall of the side of the
conservatory and then along the top
just below the eaves of the conservatory
there's a
a row of um
um there's a row of windows albeit
they're very small windows because
they're
no um between the eaves of of the
conservatory and
the top of the the wall and the wall
appears to be
higher than the height of the fence
where would they move from the side
extension actually
be then in relate those windows it's a
sloping roof isn't it
yes let me see if i can
um
um we have to accept that any form of
development we grant plan
for will have some level of harm whether
it's
impact on neighbours noise car parking
etc
but always we have to consider if the
harm is to such a degree
it results in material harm that wants a
reason
for refusal um when it comes to impact
on
neighbours one of the important things
is impact on their ability to enjoy
their own personal property which you
know is fair enough
is a material consideration but one of
the things that is clear is
the protection of habitable
accommodation is
infinitely larger and more protected
than
non-habitual accommodation and habitable
accommodations things such as lounges
bedrooms and uh non-habitat with
bathrooms
and kitchens et cetera and a
conservation would normally fall under
non-habitable
um obviously as we've seen from the
photo that was matthew's show there are
some high-level windows above that
fence line but also as ms matthews
showed is that
the sea the roof is glazed and as you
can see
through the roof you could actually see
that there's more glazing
on the end elevation so my professional
advice would be
that the loss of any light even if
though all of those high level windows
were totally obscure glaze
would be relatively de minimis in the
big picture and have a limited impact on
the
ability to actually enjoy that property
in planning terms them a
bit professional rights thank you thank
you
yes can i come back on that then
chairman
because it's rather ironic that the
issue only arises because
the person on the other side has got
in first with the conservatory extension
and it seems rather ironic to try and
claim
loss of light because of something that
they've done
which simply relies upon light coming
from the
neighbour's property
thank you thank you oh mr johnson
yeah just point out something
practically as well um
if you if mrs miss matthews can bring
back the
plan showing the properties
um yeah
the the the extension extends from the
back wall
of the main house it replaces the
existing conservatory
it only extends one meter beyond
the flat roof single-story element of
the adjoining property
so there's only one meter
of the new extension which extends into
the
side wall of the conservatory and that
is the sloping element
so it's an element that is lower than
where the side windows of the
conservatory so
in practical terms there's going to be
very limited if any
impact on that can on the windows of
that conservatory so just from a
practical point of view that should just
be born in mind
if not all but significant amounts of
those side windows will remain
unobscured by the extension thank you
chair
thank you mr johnson council sean to see
is that a legacy or did you want to come
back
if i could um briefly chairman thank you
um i'd like to thank mr johnson for
um pointing that out and and i
certainly um hope that that is the case
um
but um i hope that you haven't felt that
i've brought this
um called this in um you know
without cause because i you know i was
worried about those windows
but if they are not as i feared going to
be
completely obscured um and then
i take mr johnson's um explanation and i
thank him for that thank you chairman
thank you council okay um
the recommendation is to approve can i
have a secondary please
second council appeal thank you
uh do you do members want to approve
this but i sent
or recorded a great advice
yes everyone agreed agreed
agreed agreed
agreed agreed actually chairman thank
you thank you very much
okay item seven any items or further
items of business
they are none uh members thank you for
your contributions and members of the
public
and i can draw the meeting to a close at
7 20 as the meeting is now closed
members are advised not to enter into
any further discussions on this forum
and to please leave the meeting promptly
thank you very much
thank you very much chairman thank you